من عمان الخبر العسكري والاستراتيجي
اللواء فايز الدولي لواء دويري جميع الطرق
المؤديه الى مدينه بخموت باتت تحت السيطره
السيطره الناريه للقوات الروسيه هذا ما
يقوله الموالون لروسيا ماذا يعني ذلك فيما
يتعلق بمعركه باخموت
يعني كافه التقارير حتى من الجانب
الاوكراني تشير الى صعوبه الوضع وان معظم
الطرق قطعت بالقوات وبعضها قطعت بالنيران
والفرق بين الحالتين ان في الحاله الثانيه
يمكن استخدام ما يسمى المرور عبر الضواحي
وليس الطرق لانسحاب مجموعات القتال ولكن
باعداد صغيره منذ اسابيع كنا نتحدث ان
الخيارات اصبحت محدوده جدا والان زادت هذه
التحديدات والتعقيدات على القوات
الاوكرانيه ماذا يعني الوضع الحالي يعني
ما هي ما هي السيناريوهات المتوقعه وما هي
البدائل الان هذه القوات الان في وضع صعب
امامها خيارات محدده اما الانسحاب وكما
قلت انسحاب مجزا وليس انسحاب منظم
بمجموعات صغيره عبر الضواحي
الغرب من اجل الالتحاق بالخطوط الدفاعيه
التي بدا الجيش الاوكراني بانشائها او ان
تستمر بالقتال وتتحول المعركه ليس معركه
احتفاظ بالارض بقدر ما هي معركه استنزاف
للقوات المهاجمه علما ان راس الحربه هي
قوات فاجنر التي تجيد القتال في مثل هذه
الظروف ريثما ريثما تحدث هناك تغيرات في
بعدين البعد السياسي او البعد العسكري
لماذا اقول ذلك البعد السياسي كان القرار
السياسي منذ اكثر من اربعين يوم التمسك في
ورغم النصائح الغربيه البريطانيه
الامريكيه ضروره اخلائها واسئله الاستفاده
من القوات الموجوده بها والتي في فتره من
الفترات قدرت ب 30 الف مقاتل
لكن الرئيس جلينسكي رافض وقال علينا ان
نتمسك بها الان السؤال هل يستطيع التمسك
بها حتى يتم انقاذ القوات من خلال
وصول قوات جديده وحتى القوات اذا كانت
متاحه لا اعتقد ان المعدات المطلوبه متاحه
لماذا عمليات كسر الطوق للوصول في جمله
واحده عمليات كسر الطوق
في هذه الحاله تتطلب معدات قتال ثقيله
ومتوسطه وهذه غير متاحه حاليا لان الاعداد
التي يتم الحديث عنها هي عباره عن مجموعه
من الدبابات اربع دبابات ودبابتين وما
شابه ذلك اذا هي معركه استنزاف ونتائجها
النهائيه اما الانسحاب غير المنظم عبره
الضواحي او القضاء عليها باختصار من فضلك
سياده اللواء لماذا تستخدم دوله كبرى
ميليشيا لماذا هي بحاجه الى ميليشيا وهل
هذا معتاد في حروب اخرى
لا لا يعني ان نتحدث عن ثاني جيش في
العالم يستخدم قوات فاجنر لا هي مؤشر ضعف
البنيه
للقوات الروسيه القوات الروسيه كاعداد رقم
رقم كبير جدا لكن كقوات ذات مفاعيل على
الارض هي انتقلت من فشل الى فشل الى فشل
وبالتالي كان البديل اللي هو دفع قوات
فاجنر ومعظمها من ذوي الاسبقيات ومقابل
شروط معينه لماذا لان الجيش الروسي فشل في
انجاز المهمه فاخذ البديل الاخر لا تحسب
لا يحسب اعداد القتلى كخسائر ومن القوى
البشريه في القوات المسلحه وبالتالي هذه
القوات اكثر انضباطا اكثر اصرارا على
انجاز المهمه اذا الخلاصه فشل الجيش
الروسي في تحقيق الهدف اجبره على اللجوء
لاستخدام الالي شيات شكرا جزيلا من عمان
الخبير العسكري والاستراتيجي اللواء فايز